[Music]
what you're looking at is the phoenix
design
it is a broader wing glider than the
basic you know dart the classic dart
idea so it's got some positive dihedral
here
a lot of weight forward you can see the
folds here a lot of weight toward the
nose
broad wing here a bit of up elevator to
counter that uh
forward center of gravity that's how all
gliders work we'll talk about that at
the very end here
but let's get going on the folding of
the phoenix
the first thing we're going to do is
make a diagonal fold that's taking the
top of the page and putting it against
the side of the page
i like to do it like this i like to move
it over and
slowly squeeze down not making a crease
yet until they get that corner lined up
and then once i find the corner
then i can just kind of pivot the edge
until it lines up with the lower layer
edge
hold that and then sweep from the top of
the page to the bottom of the page
and i find most of the time i don't
sweep from one end of the other
one end to the other on a fold like that
because you end up adding errors but
on this one getting that corner nailed
down
and then sweeping is kind of important
now i miss the corner just a little bit
so
what do you do if you miss a corner what
do you what do you do if you just miss a
crease well
early on like this you just make an
adjustment so
i just missed the corner a little bit
i'm going to pull this layer down until
the corner lines up perfectly
again i'm going to press that down
and i'm just not going to give it a
choice i'm going to press it down and
hold it right there
and then line that up and make remake
that crease so that was just a tiny bit
off
at the corner and so the technique was
to pull this down
you could do it the other way you could
push it up if you missed on the other
side
but i want a really tight corner there
and that's just good practice so
so if i had missed like this
and the top layer was just a little bit
short i would pull down like i did
if i missed the other way if i miss this
way and the top layer is too long
like that i would push it back up now
you can see i've put
three creases in the paper here um in
pretty short order
um but i'm not going to worry about that
because it's early on in the plane
and it's not going to make a big
difference i'm going to end up burying
these folds so if you make a couple of
adjustment creases early on
it doesn't end up being that big of a
deal and it's way better to get it right
right off the start okay so i'm going to
unfold this
and i'm going to make a diagonal fold
the other direction i'm going to take
the top and put it against this
side and again i'm going to use my
diagonal fold technique here
i'm going to find that corner hold it
down
pivot the edges together here hold it
tight and then sweep from the top to the
bottom how do they do on that corner
that corner came out great no adjustment
necessary
that's great so i'm going to open that
up i've got a big x in the page
and now i'm going to take this side the
right hand side and put it against the
diagonal crease right here
and it's just going to come over i'm
just going to lay that whole
edge over all the way down to where the
crease meets the edge of the page and
i'm going to
take my time i'm going to line it up all
along the edge here and i'm just lining
up this edge with that crease
i can just barely see the crease and all
the way along there all the way down to
this corner here
and then i'm going to slowly flatten
this and again i'm going to start in the
middle of the crease
and sweep up start in the middle crease
and sweep down that way i'm not adding
errors all the way from one side to the
other
and you get a nice tight fit right along
that crease there
now i could unfold this to do the other
side but the way this particular plane
works out i know that i can take this
corner crease
and put it right at the end of this
crease and everything else is going to
line up really nicely
again started at the center swept down
start the center and sweep up
that's just good folding practice let's
get in the middle starting in the middle
in the practice of starting in the
middle of your crease and sweeping both
directions
you'll have less errors adding up now
you can see some of the
some of the creases here that the early
creases that i made just to kind of
demonstrate mistakes
i actually did make a mistake even a pro
makes a mistake occasionally
so we're going to now follow this big
crease here the really definite one
that we ended up with and i'm going to
fold down just straight down along that
crease
something that's not obvious something
that i'm doing here that you might not
notice is i'm
holding these layers down with my thumbs
as i'm moving this layer over
and that's to keep the wings nice and
flat i'm just kind of pushing those up
just to make sure that that crease stays
honestly where it's supposed to be
and i'm going to get a little bubbling
here we're going to address that at some
point
you know we're going to do a sweeping
move to flatten that out you want your
wings to stay flat
but right now we're just going to let
that happen
so now we're going to make a center
grease and a lot of people wonder why
you don't make a center crease first a
lot of people prefer to make the center
crease first
i don't like that because if you make
that center crease you've got a definite
place that layers will slip and slide to
one side
and again you'll end up with more
bubbling on one side than the other it's
just
it's like building in a way for errors
to be created so i don't like that i
like to wait as long as i can to do the
center crease so
this is what we're doing here so i'm
going to flip it over
and rotate it so the short edge is
pointed to the left
and i'm going to fold it in half and
paint i'm going to pay particular
attention
to the rear corners this is going to be
the back of the plane all of the
fine-tuning that's happened uh happens
right here at the back of the plane
um you know left right turning up down
all of that happens there
so i'm going to line up the front
corners line up the back corners the
middle corners
i'm going to note but i'm not going to
really stress out about getting those
guys perfect
so here we go our fold in half let's get
these rear corners lined up nicely
kind of hold that down try to get the
front corners
lined up i'm gonna have to work with
this edge right here
and i'm gonna press that again go back
here make sure that's good now that i've
got that pressed i'm gonna start in the
center
of the fuselage crease sweep to the rear
start in the center press flat and sweep
to the left there and so
again every time you make a crease think
about
less error adding up that's that's the
main thing
okay so this one actually turns out
pretty flat on this side i'm going to
give it a little sweep anyway i'm going
to start right here at this corner and
sweep up just to make sure it's nice and
flat
i'll flip it over i get a little more
bubbling on this side than the other
side
once again let's start at this corner
give it a nice hard pressure
sweep upward and just really flatten out
those layers
so that the wings will stay really
really squeezed together you want
all the layers just really as compact as
you can get them in a paper airplane
now we're going to take this edge and
put it down to our center crease
and it's going to look just like that
make a nice
sharp point there even uh in a crease
that short
still i just like to start there sweep
up start there
sweep down even even in a crease that
short
it's a little bit crazy but you know
accuracy is really
really important in paper airplane so
let's flip it over i'm going to do the
same thing to this side
move that down right there
nice sharp creases by the way i'm using
24 pound paper here it's always a good
idea
when the first time through a plan to
use 20 pound paper it's just
lighter it's easier to fold when you get
a lot of layers going
this is i just have this laying around
it's what i use for my performance
planes that i travel around the country
with
um so i have a lot of that so now we're
going to make a wing crease
before we make the wing crease the
locking fold
now here's where it gets a little
sketchy there's a part of this locking
crease that might rip on you so
let's open this up open up the center
crease
and what we're going to do is move this
little flap up over those two folds
there i'm going to move in a little bit
here
and this flap because of the way the
paper is layered there's really not
quite enough slack
to get up over here and then remake the
center crease so what we're going to do
is just start to bend that up and you're
going to see a little crinkle start to
form there
and you're going to let that crinkle
form and i'm not really going to make
the crease all the way straight across
until i get that going up and then i'm
going to remake the center crease
and that crinkle is going to add just
enough slack so this will lay flat
so that turned out exactly the way i
wanted it
let me show you what happens this is
what can happen here so
if i flatten this guy out and i move
this
all the way up and try to not have a
crinkle
here's where perfection will kill you if
i try to not have a crinkle here
let me straighten that out and i move it
all the way up and i start to fold in
half
chances are i'm going to get
i got the layers stretched out just
enough i'm not getting a rip forming
there
that was that's a miracle fold usually
you'll get a little rip going
right there right right there where
those layers meet
and get a particularly tough piece of
paper here that stretched well and it
didn't rip
so i got lucky there's a little tiny a
little tiny bit of a rip going there but
a lot of times you'll get a rip about
halfway down
not a big deal but if you let the
crinkle happen and then work the crinkle
uh and let the let the crinkle kind of
help you wrap around
it works better i'm going to zoom just
just zoom out just a skoshe so you can
see this wing crease happen
so to make the wing crease we're going
to start close to the nose the
crease is going to rake up as we go this
way and what you want to do is
start moving the wing over and you'll
see that as you bring the wing
layer close to the back of the plane
you'll see a little triangle form there
keep pulling the wing down until that
triangle just disappears and right there
is where you make the crease and i press
down all along that curve there and i'm
going to
press and sweep to the rear and press
and sweep to the front
and notice that it doesn't land exactly
on the nose you're going to be a little
bit
off the nose which is okay that's it's
actually preferable
when you when you transfer this
technique to the world record plane
you're going to need that little bit of
gap right there
okay let's flip it over i'm going to
make the other wing match and again i'm
taking some time here
and lining up exactly where the crease
ended at the nose i'm just kind of
pressing down with a fingernail right
there
where that crease is going to start that
gives me a good starting point rolling
over
and really the the critical thing is
these two corners
you want this corner and this corner to
really
tightly line up that's so that the wings
will be exactly the same width back here
you want it to all be one surface at the
back of the plane
that's just good folding technique if
you always keep an eye on those rear
corners
the plane's wings come out the most
symmetrical you can make them
so get those corners going get the front
going there
and again i'm going to slowly keep those
corners lined up and then slowly press
this flat sweep to the back
and then press it flat and sweep to the
front and i kind of sneak up on making
wing creases
i just keep moving it and moving it
until it gradually turns into a crease
rather than just like slamming it down
and swiping and making a crease
just really just kind of keep those
corners lined up and just
just keep working it as the corners line
up and and press it and then sweep
so that's that's one way to make more
accurate creases
now the plane is complete a couple of
adjustments for this paper airplane or
almost
any other paper airplane that are going
to help it fly better the first one
is dihedral angle and what we're going
to do is make the wings slip upward
and if the wings are sloping upward
that's gonna make the plane
if it gets rocked to one side the weight
will swing back under the body of the
plane swings back into the wings and
it's just
just like a pendulum it swings back to
neutral so what we do is we hang on to
it
right there where all the layers meet
right where a little lock is and put a
finger on one side
and one and a thumb on the other and
we're just going to lift it up
until we pinch it together i'm lifting
right there where all the big
layers are at the front of the plane and
then i let go and now look i've got
positive dihedral angle positive
dihedral angle just like that
if it gets rocked to one side it'll
swing back to neutral now it's very
tempting at this point to throw the
plane
because you've got a completed plane and
if you do if you were to throw it right
now
it would fly out nose over and crash
and this is where most people come to
the conclusion that they can't fold
a good paper airplane you've just folded
a very good paper airplane you've just
thrown it before you've done the final
and one of the most important
adjustments which is a little up
elevator
right back here so if you're new to
paper airplane making
i'm going to suggest that you put the up
elevator in right here
at the corner of the wings it's just
easier to get to it's a little easier to
manipulate
and the reason for up elevator
is that we've got all of this weight
forward here all of these layers forward
and you've got all these lifting surface
behind here so the plane is going to
naturally nose over like i said if
before you make that adjustment if you
throw it
it's going to go out there and nose over
and crash and that's a good sign it
means you've folded a very good plane
because all
gliders need a lot of weight in the nose
to recapture some speed
that's lost to drag so if the nose
points down i'm getting a gravity assist
i'm heading toward the ground picking up
speed
that's good but if you don't do anything
else it just goes bonk
so what you do is add a little up
elevator the air goes down the wings
when the plane gets just enough speed
enough air is reflecting off of those
elevators to push the tail down which
lifts the nose up
and that keeps the plane at a nice even
glide it's gaining speed and the nose
stays up
when everything is just balanced when
you've got just enough up elevator
to balance where the center of gravity
is you get a nice level flight
if your plane starts porpoising you've
got too much up elevator
if it's not nosing up enough if it's not
achieving a level glide you don't have
enough so
you just keep adjusting the up elevator
based on what the plane is doing you're
never really finished
adjusting a paper airplane that's
important to remember we made
adjustments to the world record plane
after every single throw on world record
day
you're never finished adjusting a paper
airplane you're always looking at it
trying to improve it
so basic up elevator idea now
we're going to get really tricky here
we're going to play with left and right
rudder
and in the same way if you adjust the up
elevators you
bend the back of the plane up to make
the nose go up
bending the rudder right here to go left
and right
is how do you correct for a turn let's
say your plane
is flying straight and it turns off to
the right and so
as it's flying it's going that way so
the nose
is going to the right so what you want
to do to correct that
is bend in just right here
just bend in a tiny bit of left rudder
and now the air will go down the body of
the plane and hit that bend and get
kicked
this way which pushes the tail that way
and if the tail is getting pushed that
way look what happens to the nose the
whole plane is
rotating around the center of gravity so
if the tail pushes that way the nose
goes that way
so this is the air traveling down here
hitting that slight little bend
air gets reflected this way the tail
gets pushed that way the nose comes back
to the left
so if i'm making a right turn i add left
rudder which is bending the back of the
plane right here
to the left just a little bit and the
same thing for right turns if i want to
get my plane to turn right i add some
right writer so here's the big tip
if whatever you want the front of the
plane to do
that's what you do to the back of the
plane up to go up
down to go down left to go left
and right to go right this is the
steering wheel the back of the plane
is the steering wheel let me zoom back
out just here just a little bit
so steering wheel right here at the back
of the plane up to go up
down to go down left to go left
right to go right and all the fine
tuning happens right here where the
wings meet the body of the plane
the phoenix broader winged more locked
together than the classic dart
a lot less drag than the classic dart
and a lot more lift
really great plane to fly flies really
well indoors around
it's the phoenix